I've only saw my dad cry once and that's  when my brother told him that  um not to call him  um it's like don't say that I'm your  that you're my father anymore and then  my dad ball dude like I remember he  literally walked to the couch covered  his eyes and he started bawling like  yeah like that Korean sorrow where he's  beating his chest and then I just  remember my brother my mom looked at my  brother just like disappointed and my  brother started tearing up he walks over  to my dad and just lays on his stomach  and he starts crying and I just remember  looking at that going you know I said  the same thing and you kicked me up  laughs  there was no core memory there was no  inside action  I was so pissed  you're like this third party  built but it's like a different color in  your head  just remember watching